de la voiture à lille i à l'équipement
électroménager la panoplie du
consommateur n'a pas de frontières on
s'en rend compte en ce moment à paris au
salon des arts ménagers salon qui
accueille moins de professionnels est
aussi moins de visiteurs que l'an
dernier le marché français n'est pas
très vaillants et il est envahie à 40%
par des fabricants étrangers cette année
les constructeurs français veulent
relever le gant en le mettant au four
le four à micro ondes l'enquète de
christian marié mono l'équipement
ménager les familles est satisfaisant
concernant le réfrigérateur
le lave-linge beaucoup moins pour le
lave vaisselle ou le congélateur
le petit électroménager ces robots de
toute nature a fait une entrée massive
dans les cuisines mais 40% les appareils
sont d'origine étrangère
ce qui n'est bien sûr pas la
préoccupation des ménagères dont le
comportement est très divers aux
manchois c'était surtout une question de
prix mais bon je connais beaucoup d'amis
qui elle achète en fonction de la marque
qui reste assez fidèle à la marche wasit
l'industrie française de
l'électroménager s'explique par trois
chiffres
une centaine d'entreprises 52 mille
salariés
trois grands noms français thomson brand
cet éboulis nex et à cela s'ajoute une
forte pénétration étrangères les
importations ont augmenté de 13% en 1981
en provenance essentiellement de
l'allemagne de l'italie et de l'espagne
les importateurs d'ailleurs en une
explication quant à l'absence
d'agressivité des français sur la tiens
à mon avis une insuffisance de moyens
qui
moyens en hommes et en installation la
prospection du marché étranger est une
chose importante coûteuse et il faut que
les constructeurs français parviennent à
cette reconquête du marché intérieur
européen que souhaite monsieur michel
jobert ministre du commerce extérieur
les constructeurs français ont déjà
réagi ici le prototype d'un four parlant
qui remplace la sonnerie traditionnel
mais est ce bien nécessaire car d'une
part les besoins des français sont
limitées ils sont plus portés vers la
hi-fi ou les magnétoscopes
d'autre part les prix d'appel qui
favorise les marques étrangères d'où une
nouvelle politique commerciale des
fabricants français
nous voulons nous mêmes nous réarmer
comparer un progrès alors en faisant
quoi
d'abord en perfectionnant l'outil
industriel
en l'automatisant
deuxièmement en faisant des produits de
meilleure qualité possible qui donne le
plus grande satisfaction consommateurs
notamment en matière de service après
vente
il est certaine nous avons une
concurrence que vous avez cités la hi-fi
aussi les loisirs en général
l'automobile est souvent pour nous un
groupe concurrent
mais nous sentons une très forte
attirance actuellement vers les
appareils ménagers notamment le petit
électroménager qui repart très fort ou
des produits comme les micro ondes
le four à micro ondes et le nouveau
cheval de bataille des fabricants
français
il peut remplacer avantageusement le
four traditionnel très répandue aux
états unis et fait lentement son
apparition en france
il est l'exemple même du dynamisme de
l'industrie française qui a su relever
le défi japonais reste bien sûr à
l'imposer dans une cuisine typiquement
française